[Music]
hello, how are you, I am going out to send with
the most outstanding headlines for
today, Wednesday, November 4, the
Secretary of State of Nevada tweeted
that there will be no more results until 9
in the morning on Thursday, this
contradicts what was said last night that  the
county will release more
results this morning meanwhile some
polling sites experienced
technical glitches prompting the
trump campaign to file a lawsuit
demanding these locations
stay open until 8
p.m.  final result
soon because many ballots
are not being processed yet let's
take a look at the five
questions included on the
ballot question 1 is about
changing the school board of
the university system in nevada wins
no so far la  question 2 is
about
same-sex marriage wins yes so far
question 3 is about same-sex marriage  conduct and
decisions of
leaders apparently it is a question 4 has
to do with the rights of voters
there are no questions 5 only the last one which
is 6 which talks about the
renewable energy initiative in our state and
now we move on to the  weather forecast
today we will have a sunny sky
with a maximum reaching 85 degrees
however the winds will return
starting Friday and the temperatures will drop
around 60 degrees
for the weekend have a
nice day I am I left Jaramillo and this
fire  his brief informative of illusion in
Spanish
[Music]